the most important thing is to
understand what the difference is
between the mind and the brain don't
take someone else's model and think that
that's going to work for you you you
need to be authentic you need to be
honest with yourself and you need to do
what you need to do to get the
productivity burnout comes from as
number one not paying attention to the
mind are there any mental exercises or
techniques as a content creator that
needs to come up with fresh ideas that
they can use to enhance their
creativity welcome back to the think
media podcast today our topic is how to
unlock the power of your brain as a
content creator and as an entrepreneur
we're going to be getting tips on how to
get out of a rut and even how to create
your best videos and tap into your
deepest level of creativity with Dr
Caroline Leaf now she is a renowned
cognitive neuroscientist with over 30
years of experience she's a legendary
author and I've been exposed to her
books now for for years like switch on
your brain your mental mess learn uh
think learn succeed in our newest book
how to help your child clean up their
mental mess and today's conversation is
going to be Super Value packed so stick
around till the end and DR leaf welcome
to the show thank you so much joh I'm
really be looking forward to this
conversation I want to start off with
just kind of some quick tips and are
there any mental exercises or techniques
as a content creator that needs to come
up with fresh ideas that they can use to
enhance their creativity well there's
there's a lot but I think the most
important thing is to understand what
the difference is between the mind and
the brain so what I can do is give you
some tips and then maybe we can dive
into why those tips are so important um
and so the one of the one of the
greatest tips for creativity is being
able to manage your mind in terms of
what you are experiencing your life so
if you are anxious or stressed or highly
worked up about stuff or not dealing
with stuff that is going that's almost a
guarantee to block your creativity so
it's really important that we that we
first major tip is that we live a
lifestyle of managing our minds and we
can talk what that talk about what that
looks like and then that helps us then
to get into a space on a psycho
neurobiological level which is your mind
brain Body Connection where you can then
start releasing your creativity and
increasing your intelligence and things
so not unmanaged toxic stress is the as
we've all experienced it's one of the
main things that will block creativity
then the another thing that is a tip
that may people may or may not have
realized but reading fiction
consistently not just now and then but
being absorbed in get there's so many
great series out there but getting
yourselves completely engrossed in
another world is absolutely vital for
creativity vital for intelligence vital
for emotional intelligence for
self-regulation it used to be CU I don't
practice anymore but it would be one of
the first things that I would write at
the top of my prescription pad for all
my patients and that would be read read
read read and read some more and in this
day and age we don't read enough and I'm
talking about fiction as well as
non-fiction I read a lot of non-fiction
I'm a researcher I'm always diving into
science articles that I make sure that I
balance that with creativity so if I'm
having a drop in my creativity one of
the first things I'm going to do is take
that time I'll take work time that we
think oh well that's just relaxation
time I will be deliberate and
intentional and I read something that's
will you take a few time an hour or half
an hour however long it takes and when I
feel the creativity coming back again
then I'll dive in and see where it takes
me and where it leads me so those are
two sort of major tips and the first one
we can dive into in more detail if you
want as we go through the interview
absolutely so chronic stress if we could
start reducing that we're going to boost
our creativity and we'll talk about how
to manage the brain but that's such an
interesting tip about reading and I'm
curious before we move on and I also
should mention that you know you've
uploaded over 660 videos and so we're
going to be talking about even content
creation but before we move on is there
a difference between ebooks digital
looking at a tablet looking at your
phone and audio books as opposed to
sitting down and actually reading words
on a page with a traditional book there
is and they each of them are a different
experience and it's a different um it's
a different psychon neurobiological
experience so psych meaning mind neuro
meaning brain and biological meaning the
physical body so that each does
something different the the interaction
with a page is still one of your classic
bests where you sit there with that book
and you're holding it and you're turning
the pages and The Sensation it
stimulates such a lot of really great
interaction also the way that your your
eyes the the light on your eyes the way
that you receive the electromagnetic
light input is very very different so
but in this technological Age We adapt
so for example I in the past and
honestly if you asked me this question
even 10 years ago I would have said to
you we should predominantly read just
paper books so I mean books hard copies
and try and not do our reading as much
online and I've changed over the years
because I've seen myself adapt and I've
seen that um that I read as much on
Kindle for example as I'm reading a book
and and it kind of depends on my mood
what work I'm doing so if I'm in doing
what uh what I was suggesting people use
reading poters creativity so if I'm
finding I need a creativity boost then I
tend to read on my Kindle because it's
so easy to copy and paste a phrase that
will stimulate me so I was doing it this
morning I was actually in my sauna and
um doing doing um I've got two phones so
the one phone won't die so I've got this
old phone that I'll use in the sa and
I'm reading this on Kindle and I needed
some stimulation for some content I'm
creating so and I'm reading this great
series I'm reading this great series and
suddenly this phrase of what one of the
characters says popped out and I could
immediately copy and highlight highlight
copy and paste that into my notes
section on my phone or was in the Google
Doc I should put it in the Google Doc
and it was it kind of just that phrase
unlocked a leash like Unleashed a whole
lot of information and creativity and
here I'm in the S sweating like crazy
and typing on my phone which I can't
obviously type as fast as when you're on
a computer but in that case that that
was work that worked very well for me
but if I'm finished work and I want to
continue just reading or I want a
different type of experience then I will
pick up a book and leave through it if
I'm searching for something if I feel
the need what was that idea what is that
what is that what am I looking for then
grabbing a whole bunch of books there's
something about that interaction of
picking up a book feeling it clipping
through the contents page you know that
kind of thing so it very much is
dependent on what you are needing in
that moment but make sure that you get a
balance of both don't just read ebooks
or audio you know that kind of thing I
mean audio is great for if you're going
for a walk and you want to listen to the
audio if you're sitting in a SAA you at
doing a workout listening to an audio
book is lovely because it's very
relaxing and and um help you keep
focused in the workout or something like
that beautiful tips and really
creativity is the most valuable currency
for Content creators and so even
thinking about what books could you
order and even breaking up your day what
a powerful tip that you might feel the
pressure to be productive but that is
productive work if you're refilling your
creative tanks I do want Circle back on
all of your powerful tips on stress but
I want to hit your experience on YouTube
first you know many doctors and authors
and people in the professional sphere uh
don't really spend time investing in
YouTube and social media so why did you
originally commit to the work of
uploading now over 660 videos and being
active even on other platforms you know
it's U probably first of all I have an
incredible team and they um they very
aware
of just you of the whole social media
importance of social media also we have
a great podcast and it's great to have
the video some people really most a lot
of people listen to Audi we know but to
have the video is really great for
certain it's just a great way so
automatically when we did when we do our
podcast we always have the video so
that's been a great tremendous help and
we have such an active podcast we
releasing two a week so that's been a
really great way of uploading content
but if you're going to reach people you
have to reach people through how people
want to be reached and you know this day
and age of Technology this is that's
what people love they want that
connection and so for us to use whatever
platform we can to reach people with the
message that we trying to bring which is
helping people manage their mind because
your mind is fundamental to who you are
no mind you're dead your mind is your
aliveness so we want to our focus on
helping people understand their mind so
that they could then be productive and
do whatever it is they do to make this
world a better place we had to we
decided to just use every platform we
could and obviously we haven't tapped
every platform but we realistic about
because they need management so as you
know so they realistic be realistic
about you know what platforms we can
reach and how to do it but I have an
incredible team that we work very
closely and that's one thing I don't um
Hive off creativity creativity is the
business I am the business I'm the core
that the stuff's coming from I I still
do clinical research so a lot of that's
the foundation of everything I do is the
research and in the research I will sit
with my teams and explain and then I
have great people that are able to then
translate this science they'll ask me
lots of questions to get the science to
a digestable point and then that's our
way then of digesting that that
digestable way of taking the science and
then bringing that to the general public
and so that's really a great very
important part of our our creativity as
well um so yeah every every platform we
can reach people everywhere because
everyone's different so we've got to be
able to tap into that that different to
get the message across and what advice
would you give to busy professionals I
think about authors thinking about the
pressures of writing uh pastors thinking
about all of the things on their to-do
list and even business owners get into
the day-to-day tasks maybe setting
realistic expectations I mean you have
uh over 235,000 subscribers 9 million
views but this took a lot of time so is
it been I mean is it a priorities thing
for you what's like the time management
to actually block out energy to create
content um I'm very glad you've asked
that question because that I know this
is something and maybe I'm going to
answer in a very unconventional way but
there's so much so many books out there
and so many courses you can do on time
management it has been a huge focus of
business for probably the last 50 years
where it's and it's become more and more
popular and you can go on time
management courses as we know and buy
time management books and do these
priorities at the end of the day my
advice to people is you know don't be
get overwhelmed by all that information
information really get to know yourself
and what you're capable of doing and
work out a time management plan that
suits you that is flexible flexibility
having a flexible you know probability
mindset when it comes to time is so
important because if I restrict myself
and say okay I'm going to spend I'm
going to do this for the first hour of
every day and then the next two hours
I'm going to do this it just does not
work for me it may work for others I'm
not saying that that's not the way to do
it what I'm saying is that don't take
someone else's model and think that
that's going to work for you you you
need to be authentic you need to be
honest with yourself and you need to do
what you need to do to to get the
productivity so people will say don't
work 15 hour days do work 15 hour days
do don't work only work 8 hours make
sure you sleep 8 hours there's just so
many rules and I take every rule as a
piece of data that's worked for someone
and I'll adapt and try and see does that
work for me and work out my own plan so
I'll listen to advice and I'll look at
at different options but at the end of
the today I work out my plan and I'm
it's so flexible I don't get thrown if I
have a plan and things don't quite work
I can adapt and that's been I think very
very key in my time management is the
ability to have a probability mindset
that yes I'd like to achieve this for
the day this for the week this for the
month or whatever but you know what
things are going to happen and I'm going
to adapt and so things don't throw me
but when I was stuck in I must get this
and this and this done and all these
calendars and things that I tried for
about 5 minutes and realize it's not
going to work for me it created
tremendous stress now for someone else
those lists those calendars those
schedules obviously we have a schedule
for appointments and you know basic
things we we keep a very very simple
schedule that is so we know exactly
what's happening in the day in terms of
of booking things but in terms of me
with managing my time um the best advice
I can give people is you find what works
for you don't try and copy someone else
because you are you make a lousy someone
else but you make an amazing you
brilliant tips and
if we were looking at the Neuroscience
of emotions as content creators we're
trying to structure videos we're trying
to write titles we're trying to put
elements in our thumbnails that of
course resonate deeply with the target
audience that we want to reach what How
could an understanding of the
Neuroscience of emotions maybe improve
the content that we create in our
messaging great question so first of all
we've got to be careful of the word
neuroscience of emotions and the reason
I say that is because in the since about
the mid90s where we've had um technology
to look inside the brain we have become
and I'm not actually going to take the
Wei out of it science has become quite
neuro reductionistic and so it's about
Brain Brain Brain Brain Brain so there's
been a massive move in the last 40 years
to make everything about the brain so
the Neuroscience of Education
Neuroscience of business neur so it's
become very trendy and um there's two
good there there good and bad the good
is that it's very important that we do
have um a development and understanding
of Science of the brain and I've been in
the field for 40 years and my
understanding of the brain now has
improved vastly but what I have learned
most ofly most of all is that the mind
the brain is not it the brain is one
part of a tripartite network which is
mind brain and body and actually the
mind is it the Mind drives the brain the
mind is not the brain and the brain and
mind collectively Drive the body and
they work as a unit tripartite unit and
that understanding shifted so if we
focus just on um Brain Brain Brain we
are going to get a very filtered
mechanistic view of human behavior and
we're going to then start trying to
follow um very specific cookie cutter
typ formulas and our creativity will go
for a loop and we see this happening by
the cycles that happen in in the trends
that that you know this works that works
and then someone just you know with Tik
Tok or whatever something goes viral and
you think but there's no rules that have
been followed but why has this gone
viral and that's what we see happening
with social media now as things go viral
or things get traction that don't seem
to follow those rules that are the rules
that seem to be the rules we should be
following to tap into the Neuroscience
of emotion so let's maybe look at it as
the the science of psychon neurobiology
and look at emotions um and looking at
it from that perspective emotions then
fall into a category of signals so
emotions no longer stand alone they are
one of four groups of signals and the so
when we have an emotion and this is very
logical stuff just think of it if you
feel excited you're going to feel that
somewhere in your body so the first
category is emotions the second category
is where do you feel that emotion in
your body and then the third category is
you know how is that influencing your
behaviors what you say and what you do
and then the fourth category how is that
improving influencing your perspectives
so emotion the Neuroscience of emotion
should shift to the psychon neurobiology
of emotion and that tells us that
emotions one of four signals and
emotions on a neuroscientific level
emotions have a chemical and protein
signature in the brain they have a
protein and chemical signature in the
body that looks different and they have
a gravitational or biofield in the mind
so they have three different
representations but those emotions never
live alone they always live with the
other other three signals and those four
signals together are always attached to
content and that content is an
experience and an experience basically
is a thought and the thought is made up
of memories I know I've said a lot so
let me just track that back so you've
got you've got um emotions as one of
four signals four buckets think of four
buckets emotions that are linked to Body
Sensations behaviors and perspectives
those are signals taking us to an
experience they're not living alone
they're attached to something and that
what they're attached to is an
experience and experience is actually
just a word for thoughts thoughts are a
cluster of memories so we have like this
conversation now we there's a lot of
stuff going on there's a lot of words
going out those words are memories so at
the DayDay is memories they're
clustering together to form a thought
that thought is how we can use
understand the brain and the mind and
psychon neurobiology when it comes to
being create cre creating content on
YouTube or social media whatever but
predominantly YouTube um and so that's
that's the name of the thought so you
had to tra name the stream would be the
name of this podcast the things we're
talking about would be the memories of
this podcast C and this whole thing is
an experience if that makes sense and
what you and I are saying like the
questions you're asking and the answers
that I'm giving would be at the root if
you think of a thought looking like a
tree and then the each every single
listener and viewer is hearing this
according to their own unique way that
they think feel and choose so think of
that as being the tree trunk so you and
I delivering the root memories and in
this experience or thought and each
listener and viewer is processing it
through the tree trunk but their own
unique tree trunk their own unique way
that their mind works in other words how
they uniquely think feel and choose and
then they grow little branches each of
us grow branches and those branches are
dependent on the unique way that the
persons perceive the information
therefore every single person listening
and viewing is growing their own cluster
of branches that is different toone else
now in those branches are all this data
and those and um those data are all then
producing those four signals so emotions
are buried within all of this stuff
because they right from the roots to the
processing they those four signals grow
all the way through and they produce how
we show up so in knowing that the
totality of the experience we need to
rather think about how big when we think
of an emotion we need to think of okay
it's going to affect all four signals
it's going to be related to an
experience there's going to be a source
and if you track that concept you're
going to give something that is very
authentic and that's what you want to
get to to get people's attention and it
may take time it may take time not
everyone gets that Viral hit and
suddenly they have 20 million followers
or they have a book A New York Times
besteller or something it's it's and we
need to also stop looking at those kind
of numbers because it's very it can
block us we need to look at numbers yes
but we need to look at the process and
the experience more and the totality of
that experience because that will help
us grow authenticity and as we grow
authenticity we will produce content
that Taps into the emotions plus the
other three signals plus the experience
plus Roots you want to you want to
attach that you want to um um dive into
that whole person's experience not just
have a surface band aid kind of thing
now that's quite a complex answer I
don't if that made sense you're welcome
to unpack it with questions yeah um very
fascinating and you know we are
listening to an expert here and we would
uh most of us as listeners obviously be
newbies to Neuroscience or be living
kind of on the surface if you were to
give us in light of all of that
information what steps we could take
practically on a week by week
month-by-month
basis to become more authentic so that
in our content and so that we create an
emotional experience or emotional
response knowing
that it could block us if we're just
trying to have a New York Times
bestseller or a viral video
but at the same time of course our
desire is to grow grow our business
reach more people and yeah and so we're
so we're wanting to okay well maybe my
content's a two right now and I want to
get it to a 10 at least within my
ability my skill set the way I
communicate and this could and then it
could go into all kinds of nuanced
things maybe the way I articulate things
and and my kind of almost my EQ my
emotional control the way I deliver
information what people feel the kind of
frequency I'm communicating on so if we
made it as simple as possible in terms
of what prescription would you give
people that they would start showing up
more authentic and really be able to
practically apply your answer the best
way to do that is to learn to manage
your mind which involves
self-regulation which involves being
very observant about yourself and the
impact you have on yourself and the
impact you have on others and that's a
life skill and it's something that you
pretty much do for your entire life and
it it improves your quality of living it
en enables you to embrace the issues of
Life the challenges of life in a way
that makes you very authentic you know
that you're not going to try and just
pathologize things or medicalized misery
it's going to be hey I embrace this
depression that I'm feeling or this
overwhelm or this burnout because
there's something that I it's not who I
am it's because of something and what is
that because of and what can I learn
this or maybe you're scrolling through
social media or scrolling through
someone else's YouTube channel and
thinking oh my gosh they've got so many
you know likes on that particular
YouTube video or they've got so or that
social media whatever they've got so
many so much content and you start
feeling envy and you start and instead
of running from that and think oh I've
got to push that down see that Envy as
an emotional signal that's actually good
for you and it's telling you something
so don't see it as a threat that you
need to suppress see it as something
that you should embrace process and
reconception Iz so in that way you shift
your neurophysiology and now you say
okay I am envious of that so why let me
unpack why let me start being very
focused on understanding that particular
emotion where does what else goes with
that Envy maybe there's a t a bit of
jealousy maybe there's a bit of
frustration at that and and that
frustration is at yourself perhaps and
then what behaviors how's that
influencing your behaviors where are you
feeding this in your body how's that
shifting to your perspective you know
ask yourself those four questions about
those four signals from that experience
and then so you gather that then you you
reflect you go into a process of
reflection and the reason that I'm going
to say this now is because we're in a
world that tells us to talk about our
feelings there's a lot of stuff on
feelings mindfulness meditation
breathing and all of those are excellent
but all of what if you just do
meditation breathing calming down
mindfulness mindfulness CBT all those
different things and you do them in an
way they're going to get your brain Mind
Body prepared for stuff but it'll be
more of a unsustainable Band-Aid
approach so what that means is that it's
going to help you in the moment but
maybe not in the long run so you may for
the moment put out the fire of the
jealousy but you haven't learned
anything from it so you may do a
breathing technique to calm you down or
you may mindfully become aware if you
feel this envy and then you push the
thought aside or you may use a CBT
technique to say okay I don't need that
Envy it's going to block my creativity
but you don't deal with it you simply
just redirect to another thought none of
of those are solving a problem none of
those are sustainable they're going to
make you feel good in the moment they're
going to give you a burst of creativity
but in the long run they're not going to
put you on a sustainable path to
creativity so I would recommend then
once you're aware that you connect all
four and then you go into deep process
of reflection and a focused reflection
is kind of like shining a white light
through a prism and if you think of it
when you shine a white light through a
prism you may or may not have done this
but it comes out as a rainbow on the
other side so the depth to reflection is
depth a point Sorry the point of
reflection is depth why am I feeling
Envy frustration and jealousy and all
these Sensations in my body why am I the
who the what the when the where the why
the how what's the pattern what's the
cause in other words you start going to
that tree seeing the branches tracking
down to your thinking process and
finding the origin and that's a
deconstruction process it's an embracing
process where you deconstruct it's hard
work it's very
painful it can be very challenging but
it's very productive
because you'll get to that point where
you realize what that Envy jealousy was
and then you can start reconstructing
and saying well you you never going to
forget that YouTube video that you saw
or that person's YouTube videos that
made you feel envious so that's never
going to go away because once you've had
an experience it's with you forever but
you can change how it's going to play
out into your future and that goes
through by doing this process you
actually shift how you are looking at
that information in your life and so you
would then go to sort of a
conceptualization phase and then create
some sort of an action that then takes
you into how am I going to deal with
this so what have I learned from this
what can I do I'm envious and jealous
because of this it actually goes down to
a base corol thing that that's really
what I want to achieve but I'm not that
person what can I achieve what's
realistic for me what can I do that's
authentic to me as a person that can
touch other people's lives why do I want
to be like that person you can't be like
that you know that's all that sort of
reconceptualization that gives us a
sense of peace and Direction and then we
can say okay well what are my action
steps now that process if you do it once
will not do anything for you it'll just
start the process it's something that
you're going to have to do daily for at
least nine weeks because what you're
doing is you are taking something that's
major to your life you're a content
creator on YouTube that's why they
listen to you so that's their major
focus and big part of their business I'm
assuming that this is the majority of
people that are listening to this so if
you want to get into that authenticity
that is going to generate the content
that will touch people's lives you going
to have to find out the things that are
blocking how you function and blocking
your creativity and using those like the
envy and the jealousy or something like
that I just gave that as a simple
example it could be something else it
could be a lack of could be shame it
could be you thinking how could I ever
help anyone else I'm not good enough or
it could be a bunch of stuff um it could
just be I just don't know how to do this
then it's then you find that out and you
get the skills and you learn how to do
it and you that kind of thing but it's
not going to you're not going to change
immediately this observation this
ability to stand back and observe
ourselves that I call the multiple
perspective Advantage where you stand
back and You observe how you're showing
up through the four signals and tracking
it through and taking it through this
process it's a planned and guided
process of observation and deep
connection that is a very conscious
deliberate intentional process that
connects you with your nonconscious and
if you do that daily for around 5 to 15
minutes over cycles of nine weeks which
is the time it takes to rewire Networks
you're going to not only deconstruct and
reconstruct something that's blocking
you but you're going to create a whole
network that's going to drive you in to
in Leaps and Bounds into another
dimension um and it may take multiple
Cycles but each cycle will take you to
that next Dimension um and it's that
work because what drives you are these
networks so that Envy is a signal of a
network that's driving you so find the
network use what's good about it fix
what's not good about it and therefore
change how it plays out into your future
but that's a there's no quick fix for
that people are in a world where we look
for give me the five steps and the quick
technique to improve my creativity I
can't do that I can tell you the planned
and guided process that works in cycles
of nine weeks because I've spent years
researching how long it takes to form a
habit and how long it takes to rewind
networks which is all related and I've
got massive studies running currently
and I've just published another paper
we've got five under in under review the
year have just published two have just
been released for publication what I'm
saying is that there's a ton of science
behind what I'm saying and the good news
is that it works the bad news is that
it's going to take time but it works hey
in just a second we're going to get
right back into this episode of the
think media podcast but if you haven't
heard for a limited time you can get 90%
off the complete package for growing a
successful YouTube channel in 2024 our
epic holiday sale includes our YouTube
shorts Master Class AI for YouTube guide
Niche Finder course YouTube starter kit
and a ticket to our live virtual event
the YouTube roadmap Workshop this bundle
of resources is valued at over
$2,500 but you can get 98% off for a
limited time at think Medias sal.com so
just go to think Medias sal.com before
this offer expires and now let's jump
back into the episode if one of the best
ways we could create better content that
resonates more deeply with people is to
be showing up more authentically to do
that going through this process and the
word I'm maybe oversimplifying down to
is that we need to grow in selfawareness
and self-awareness is a lifelong process
and going in reflecting and having where
is this emotion coming from where is
that coming from doing that work helps
us grow in
self-awareness and I've often heard it
said self-awareness is a superpower
especially for an entrepreneur a leader
a content creator but am I
oversimplifying just by calling it
self-awareness or at least is that
somewhat accurate it is oversimplifying
and it's and there's no and no criticism
intended it's it's totally
understandable because that's what's the
word emotions emotional intelligence um
Neuroscience of emotions and awareness
are all over the business literature and
all over media and are used incorrectly
so it's not incorrect for you to say it
like that but there's so much more
awareness is one of it's just there
there's different types of awareness but
it's and it's only the first stage
there's four more stages after that and
there's a preparation stage prior to
that that then gets you into the the
into the
the right direction so the better word
would be
self-regulation which includes um the
concept of awareness plus so much more
so because because awareness
incorporates things like mindfulness and
you get General awareness and focused
awareness and it incorporates as I said
things like mindfulness but that's not
enough you've got to go beyond that and
um so mind management that is the term
that I use that is then training when
you manage your mind you're basically
training this concept of self-regulation
so your superpower is mind management of
which the tool is
self-regulation and self-regulation um
is when you self-regulate and mind
manage you are changing those Networks
you're doing all the stuff that I've
been saying and so what I did to make it
simple for my patients years ago when I
was working with people with dementias
and Parkinson's and you know ADHD and
autism and severe trauma then adapting
that just to life and living and you
know the things that are not so
traumatic but that are just bad habits
we develop and day-to-day struggles I
developed to system um that is a system
that you can fit all these different
mindfulness and CBT and techniques that
are great great advice that's out there
um what I saw lacking was great advice
but I didn't what I didn't see um was a
way to put this together that it
actually changes the networks in your
brain and therefore drives
neuroplasticity in the direction that it
should go in so the system of develop
which I actually was describing the
previous step I just didn't name it is
called the neuros cycle and the neuros
cycle then is incorporating the elements
of awareness Ness so the neuros cycle is
the name of the Mind management tool
that you use to develop self
self-regulation and can be adapted to
business to education to dealing with a
relationship because it's basically how
you manage your mind it's basically a
life skill so it's a raw fun fundamental
principle into which you can put
anything and so you the first thing you
would do excuse me is prepare you
prepare the brain and that's where
things like breathing and meditation and
mindfulness exercises and decompression
and all those kinds of things come in
then you would go into the awareness
that mind all that preparation stuff
will create General awareness and will
create you know the awareness of your
body and sounds and and Sensations and
thoughts moving through your mind and
that kind of thing um and generally the
instructions from those is you know let
the thoughts crash on the beach or that
kind of thing but you you can't stop
there the equivalent of doing that and
not doing anything else which I call
pretty much band-aiding it's going to
help but it's a Band-Aid approach the
equivalent if we took something like
flying flying an airplane would be the
preparation that is done before a plane
takes off so for example you've got your
pilot you got your co-pilot you've got
your engineers you've got all the rules
and there incredible procedures that are
involved there's a tremendous amount of
preparation before a plane takes off but
if you only do the preparation the plane
stays in the air in the airport and
doesn't go anywhere so you don't want to
do that with your life you don't want to
just have your creativity all like
primed but it doesn't really go anywhere
so now from there you need to move to
the next phase which is taking off which
is a very planned and guided process
once again and that's now where you
gather awareness so it's not just
general awareness and mindfulness which
you need first you have to have that it
primes you now you've start taking off
and that's where you now gather
awareness so the word gather is very
selective it implies selectivity it
implies Choice it implies control it
implies empowerment it implies internal
locus of control you are driving what am
I going to focus on on and that's where
your four signals would come into play
you would gather awareness of those then
once you're flying if you know how to
take off but you don't know how to fly
you crash so we see from a lot of the
literature that people on a um mental
health level if they just prepare
meditation mindfulness and they talk
about just emotions they crash because
they don't know what to do with what
they've brought up in terms of business
creativity developing content if you
just prepare and you just take off it's
going to be the authenticity missing
there's something missing it's just
going to be stimulating people but it's
where's this going so we have to it'll
crash so what we have to do is take it
further you have to fly and the flying
then is where we go into a deep
reflective stage that light shining
through the prison where you asking the
who what when where there's that
reflection on why trying to get to the
processing in the root there's you've
got to capture that and there's a way
that you capture in a written form that
I call a medog that is not journaling
but it um pulls on our ability to
connect the conscious with the
nonconscious and activate creativity to
another level totally and really opens
up the networks of the brain and mind
and then you um that once you've done
that step the next step of flying
there's three steps to fly is to then do
reconceptualization or rechecking which
is this this has happened what do I do
it's the plans you make the patterns and
so on and then you need to translate
that into action which just becomes lots
of words and lots of ideas now what are
your action so your your Landing the
plane would be then be the first step
which would be the active reach so that
concept can be applied on in creating
content physically creating content you
can go through that process as a sort of
brain building exercise but you can also
use that same process to work on your
mental state which could be blocking
because could you could be in toxic
stress which is giving you brain frog
and memory issues and your creativity is
just not there so you could use it to
find out why am I in this state then you
could do some reading of you know St
some the the fiction that our spoke
about so you could do a medic I mean you
could do a neuros cycle in 15 minutes
you could read for an hour and then you
could do another neuros cycle to create
content so it's a brain the same five
steps but you use it for brain building
so you use it slightly differently and
where you create generating content and
that combination of three will put you
on another level it's what I do pretty
much with all my work so I want to
welcome everybody to the PHD level of
the think media podcast and uh this is
very powerful and for those that are
sticking with us I
think the first thing I just want to ask
briefly
is is there one main book or multiple
books where you break this down because
I know our listeners that are seeing how
powerful this is but also seeing okay
self-awareness is which book is it so I
would yeah this I would recommend this
book to start with cleaning up your
mental mess this is a great first start
because the first part's a bit sciency
but it's easy reading the second part is
the detail of how to do the neuros cycle
and in different applications like the S
and brain building I also have this in
an app so we have a mental health
technology platform and so the me the
app is called neuroc cycle which is easy
because the neuros cycle is that system
and in that I then walk you through
there's decompression activities there's
brain preparation activities and then I
walk you through the 63 days how to do
the five steps over 63 days and then you
can adapt that once you understand the
basic process you can then adapt that we
also are building by January we'll have
a webinar feature inside the app where
people can then ask questions and it
becomes an interactive community so that
would be this would be a great place to
start and the app I would start with
those two because it's actually the me
literally walking you through the
process step by step and helping you to
apply it in in your context incredible
so many more questions to come and uh
more insights but definitely check out
in the show notes um cleaning up your
mental mess and that's going to walk you
through doing this and then check out
neuros cycle and um you actually uh you
sent us a code to neuros cycle 20 where
people can grab 20% off any subscription
so rather than necessarily even
understanding everything you broke down
knowing you have the science you have
the experience you've got the results
following the app step by step and you
just blew my mind because obviously I am
much more on the surface level of
Entrepreneurship and business Buzz words
and so oh self-awareness is a superpower
and you're like no actually mind
management
self-regulation neuro Cycles being in a
process of being able to have deep
reflection
reconceptualization and then taking
action actually building your brain
which was layers of Distinction and
Mastery there and of course on the other
side I love what you said is this isn't
easy so if somebody was listening to
this episode looking for some quick fix
or quick hack um there's Maybe Band-Aids
here or there breathing exercise or
something like that but you're really
looking to transform the people you
impact myself our community everybody
you serve that they could go to a whole
another dimension as you said by going
through these neuros Cycles by putting
in the work for 63 days and actually
seeing uh level upon level upon level of
us tapping into the next version of us
creativity wise tapping into the next
version of us as entrepreneurs as
parents as people and so this is all so
powerful I do we promised earlier that
we would Circle back on some practical
things we could do to address this big
thing that you mentioned which was
stress or toxic stress and anything else
that maybe is blocking our brain health
and our brain fog fog uh and causing
brain fog I'm convinced um or I know
that our community is struggling with
this if not daily consistent stly
wanting to do something oh man I want to
take action on the advice Sean gives I
want to I've got some ideas but there's
that block there and so what have what
are some tips for maintaining good brain
health um or specifically the stress
because that's really what you mentioned
earlier and You' already shared many so
is there any other direction you want to
take it besides going through a neuros
cycle or some of these other things well
I think the principal Sean thanks for
asking that question it's a really
important question um and it's one that
we don't you know we all aware of stress
and things like that but we don't really
fully understand that stress is actually
good for us and we can embrace it and
recognize when it's when it's tipping so
stress is it's kind of like a balancing
act you know it's good for us if we
managing it but if we don't it becomes
you know tips and it can pull us down
and so um essentially the the the
probably the most important thing is to
realize that you can't change what's
happened to you but you can change what
it looks like inside of you so the power
to know that you can you can drive what
the networks look like in your brain you
can actually change them and you can
change what it looks like inside of your
body and and your mind and that then
changes how you how you function that
that knowledge is very empowering um it
gives people hope and and that's really
I think key to to to starting this and
enabling people to move forward then the
other thing is also to realize that
these are skills that we build that we
naturally are resilient as humans we
naturally are brilliant but these are
skills that we need to build over time
so mind management is something that we
have to practice um and you know mind if
if you think of mind and if you think of
what is the difference between mind and
brain that could help us understand
stress better because your brain is not
the thing that's doing the stress it's
your mind that's doing the stress so
messy mind messy brain messy body messy
life so if you are consistant telling
yourself I have to work 15 hours a day
which every day is going to wipe you out
because your brain is like your cell
phone it gets tired and so you may think
at hour 14 hey I've done 15 hours I'm
really great and then you wonder why you
feel depressed the next day because
you've worn your brain out and you've
worn your conscious mind out your
non-conscious mind doesn't get tired but
it it's it constantly send signals to
your conscious and and your brain your
brain to relax so your brain is physical
it's a physical organ if you dead your
brain is disintegrating but the fact
that you're alive and able to listen to
this podcast and watch this um watch
this podcast you are making 800,000 to a
million cells every second because
you're alive because of your mind your
mind is driving your physiology your
mind is driving Your Capacity to build
between 800,000 and a million cells
every second I mean just let that sink
in if you did you're not building those
cells so the but the qu those cells then
make up every organ of your body and
every system of your body and that
physical part is what your mind is using
for you to function in life so if the
quality of my mind management is poor
the quality of the cells that I make are
poor therefore the quality of my body
and over time the way I'm physically and
mentally going to show up is going to be
impacted so messy mind messy brain messy
body messy life so that understanding is
pretty key in the first part of the app
and and that book I do talk about this
and a lot of my podcast that people can
hear this all the time with my stuff but
it's really key then the other thing is
that there's so much hope because you
can we've got this wisdom in us so as we
talk about messy it's okay to be a mess
it's okay to be a mess embrace your
messiness because life and humanity is
messy you're not going to know you're
not going to always do the right thing
and say the right thing and it's all
experimental and that is very very
normal what is also normal is to manage
the messiness so it's oh gosh I got
irritated okay I got irritated it's okay
I'm not going to beat myself up I'm
going to accept that I got irritated and
I'm going to work out why and what am I
going to do about it that's very
different to I got irritated again I
hate myself I keep getting irritated and
then you're going to regret if only I
didn't do that now I've messed up
another relationship or now I've messed
up another and so you go down and oh now
I've wasted three hours worrying now
I've lost more creativity and you know
that cycle just burns and I've got to
generate this income and you know it
becomes this very toxic cycle whereas if
you can recognize okay I was messy I
made a total mess I messed up for three
hours in everything I did today or
whatever that's okay what am I going to
do about it and you go through a neur
cycle saying okay I was messy um this
and this and that ability of you to
stand back and observe yourself and give
yourself permission to be messy and say
okay now let's manage this messiness
that is key in in um managing toxic
stress because you then work through the
neuros cycle you get to the point of
acceptance and you realize it's not who
I am it's what I'm going through and
it's okay I can get through this even if
I did upset other people what am I going
to do I'm going to find a way to
apologize I'm it's okay we all mess up
we we that'll stop us being so hard on
ourselves
this ability that we have to have these
conversations with ourselves is our wise
mind so as neuroscientists what we see
is that our psychon neurobiology our
mind brain Body Connection is wired for
love and I love telling people this it's
literally you've heard my work you've
heard me say this before we don't have a
single protein right structure protein
right down to the subatomic level in our
mindbrain body connection that is wired
for anything but survival everything's
on our side we have this enormously
infinite nonconscious not unconscious
unconscious is when you asleep not
subconscious subconscious is a portal
not conscious that's when you're awake
we have a non-conscious that's your
driving force it is where your
intelligence your wisdom your wful of
nature every experience is stored and
it's your pretty much the core of your
aliveness it then works with the
subconscious which is just a doorway and
the conscious which is awake when you're
awake your conscious and
subconscious your conscious mind is very
slow in comparison to your nonconscious
you've got this enormous nonconscious
that has every experience that you've
ever had built into these thought trees
and your nonconscious working with your
within your mind brain body with your
brain reacting to your mind because your
brain's just the physical the mind's
making all of this stuff work on a
psychological and neurophysiological
level but this combination this wide for
love combination of our psychon
neurobiology driven by the nonconscious
is on your side and it's searching and
seeing okay that cluster of thought
trees over there is dark dark cluster of
trees and that is messing with your
creativity and your productivity so that
needs to be addressed and it may have
absolutely nothing to do with your
current work but it's got something to
do with something that happened in
childhood or something that happened
recently in your relationship or with a
best friend or something and it's become
dominant and it keeps coming back every
time you're trying to do something the
thoughts they said this they said that
they doing this they doing that they and
at night you find yourself you're
driving your car and you find yourself
those intrusive thoughts you need to
make them your best friend you need to
know what to do to you need to step into
that nonconscious mind and recognize
your nonconscious mind is sending those
thoughts up through the subconscious
into your conscious mind and the reason
you keep thinking about them is because
your nonconscious is telling you to
think about them in order to process
them so they don't control you and you
control them but what do we do we say oh
I must think about that and we shove it
down what do you do five minutes later
you think about it again but it's worse
than it was before so if you don't
manage something and you keep thinking
about it it gets bigger and bigger and
more disruptive to your functioning so
what we want to do is really listen to
the depths of those messages that are
moving from the nonconscious to the
subconscious interc conscious mind
through those signals attach to those
intrusive thoughts and take the time to
step into wful of Nature and stand back
and observe why am I in this mess at the
moment it's okay to be there but why am
I in this mess what can I do okay that's
related to that I need to allocate 15
minutes every morning for the next 63
days to resolve this issue so and then
then you compartmentalize and say okay
now I'm going to do that that so for the
rest of today I'm now going to work on
whatever I have to work on and that kind
of thinking is critical to to taking you
to another level creatively wise this is
also fascinating I've got some
spontaneous questions for you that um
I'm actually deeply passionate about
from your expertise there's a big Trend
right now called neurot Tropics or neut
Tropics brain drugs um a lot of times
vitamins or different concoctions um I'm
imagining it's probably a pretty
lucrative industry and it's growing and
lots of people are launching energy
drinks or drinks or in pill form and
maybe even deeper than that there's
whole the whole biohacking movement
what's your take do any of these work do
you encourage people to be leery of them
and are there natural things that we can
do to support better brain health so
thank you that's a great question so
first of all um as humans we're always
looking for a quick fix so it sounds so
wonderful to be able to put a device on
your head to take a new Tropic to take a
supplement and think okay that's going
to solve my sleep issues that's going to
solve my but they're not going to solve
it they're going to be part of the
toolbox so I think all of them do have a
place I mean as science is advancing you
know the science of neut Tropics it's
still pretty new but it's you know and
unfortunately supplement industry is not
regulated which is unfortunate but at
least there is some good science that's
happening out there so I wouldn't I
would say that they are all part of the
toolbox but if you look at them as being
a solution like if I go and lie on this
bed and do that amount of that
simulation you know there sound bars and
there's these Labs you can go to and you
can I mean there's so many devices you
don't even have to go anywhere you can
put them on your wrist on your watch
these things that you can put all over
you and onto you and um they can help
you with you know there's one that you
can put on your chest and your chest is
like a cathedral and it sends sound
waves through your chest and it can that
sensation can calm you down I mean if
you're feeling really worked up do that
but don't think it's the solution it's
part of the entire solution in fact the
percentage that those biohacks play if
you had to if I had to give you an
estimate it's around about 10% of
supporting how you function so I would
put biohacks diet exercise and people
are going to think I'm crazy but I'm
going to justify this now but do them
but they form about 10% and a very
valuable 10% of your functioning the
other 90% is mind the most important
heck is your mind because your mind is
your aliveness and your aliveness what
we know from how the mind drives your
neurophysiology like I said you making
800 to million cells every second the
quality of those cells depends on your
mind not on the biohack not on the neut
Tropic those are just giving you raw
materials that hopefully you're going to
be able to utilize but if your mind's
not working you won't use the neut
tropics anyway you can take as many as
you want but they're not they'll give
you a burst of energy and a little bit
of benefit but it's going to be band aid
once again so we know from the research
for your body cells to actually
assimilate that neut Tropic for your
brain to take advantage Your Mind Body
Connection to take advantage of that
vibration that's moving through your
your Cathedral like thorax um and your
you know behind your ribs that the the
cavity that it makes you have to have
your mind under control so you've got to
work on the 90% and that's where I
believe there's a massive Gap sh and
which is what I'm trying to address with
my work is let's work on the 90 because
we spending 100% of our time on the on
the 10% and zero time on the 90% or
maybe maybe it's 9% on the all that 1%
on the mind and we've got to get the
Mind dominant and then we can add all
those in as needed you don't need all of
them you need to work out what works for
you what is Affordable and what's
workable you just blew my mind because
as a as a type driven entrepreneur that
you know eventually sees a Dave aspery
um and a Tim Ferris and Bulletproof
Coffee um it's really it's really easy
to get into all of this biohacking but
literally to say that that's 10%
including diet and exercise and that 90%
is the mind it really shines a light and
I think that is a huge unlock moment for
all of us to think about man we got to
take this seriously and waiting for us
on the other side of improving our mind
management and our self-regulation and
building up our brain man is Untold um
Dimensions as you're saying of new
Energy new creativity I'm curious
because you get to work with so many
highlevel people and and type A driven
people like me I think about the
entrepreneur wiring the content creator
wiring what makes that kind of
entrepreneur wiring specifically sub
susceptible to burnout what is it about
driven people and probably many
ambitious people that listen to this
podcast all different personalities but
they want to build something create
something get out there start a side
Hustle but maybe not just burnout what
are some of the other cautions that that
personality type should be thoughtful of
and I heard it said this way there's a
book called The Entrepreneur roller
coaster I don't know if it's just
entrepreneurs but sometimes we could be
susceptible to radical swings and really
high highs and really low lows and
building our brain mind management could
help us but why is that that maybe we're
particularly success to burnout
excellent question and if I may I think
that the susceptibility to burnout
applies to literally anyone so you can
take a mom who's trying to juggle four
kids or something or people that are you
know parenting and working or people
that are in a job not unnecessarily an
entrepreneur and just being alive
dealing with what's going on around us
so people are very um burnt out I think
it's the problem has increased with
technology technology is fantastic I
have no problem with social media I'm
not one of those people that says social
media causes problems what I say it's
not the social media it's your
management of the social media once
again it's not the physical it's the
mind it's the 90% behind that's what we
got to pay attention to so burnout comes
from us number one not paying attention
to the mind and pushing not learning to
listen to when we have those very strong
messages from our wise mind telling us
to slow down telling us to speed in
different ways telling us to focus on
different things in different ways so
I'm obsessed with psychon neurobiology
and Neuroscience I have a full research
team I can go for 15 hours without even
realizing but I've learned to listen to
my body I've learned to manage that
otherwise I will burnout and there are
times that I have recogniz I've trained
myself to recognize the signs of burnout
and so susceptibility to burn out yes
some people are definitely we can
definitely agree some people are will
push themselves more than others others
will they kind of burnout is more I
they'll pull back and they'll do nothing
kind of do much less but there's others
that will just burn those those bridges
and burn those hours remember think of
it like this your nonconscious mind
knows what you can handle and it knows
exactly CU it's your wi of nature it
knows what you need to survive and what
you need to survive is periods of rest
so your brain does your brain is
honestly like a cell phone it does it
goes flat and if you still trying to
push your mind ideas your mind part the
bio energy of Your Mind through a
physical brain that's now kind of
winding down you know your cell phone
doesn't work very well once you put all
those apps open and you once it crashes
you can't do anything with your brain
your your cell phone and that's the same
sort of thing so it's once again it's
learning to listen to those signals and
those signals might be right at this
moment you need to take a thinker moment
and I teach a lot about thinker moments
and a thinker moment is around about
every 45 minutes to an hour taking 2 to
3 minutes to just let your mind wonder
and that activates the default mode
Network which I know was one of the
questions you were interested in asking
me about the default mode Network
enables and when it's activated in a
think a moment it your mind is basically
telling your brain to restore and
replenish and it allows a lot of firing
of energy around the different parts of
the brain to restore and replenish and
in doing that lots of thoughts will
start popping up and you don't have to
do anything with them in that thinker
moment you just have to let your mind
wonder and then you when you stop you
kind of time it around about you know 30
seconds to a minute every 45 minutes and
then try and take 10 to 15 minutes every
um at least once during the day and then
at the end of the time period make a few
notes of the thoughts that have come up
now you may not have time to go work on
them at that moment because you've got
work to do with things that your
meetings in that you're in or something
but make a decision to put that into
your neur cycle work I recommend people
spend allocate 15 to 45 minutes a day
deliberately working on using the neuros
cycle to manage whatever is going on in
your life and U so if things pop in
those mind wandering moments things will
come up that are potentially depleting
your energy and that's what happens I
get pushed through the default mode
Network time when you when you do a
thinker moment you activate the
nonconscious mind to activate the
default mode Network to send through
messages to you via thoughts of what you
need to work on and so that's why I say
write them down and when you find the
time go work on those because those are
the things that are your energy and
pushing you to burn out and those are
the things that will tell you things
like okay you're worrying too much about
this person you way too you trying to
fix that person you actually can't you
need boundaries and if you carry on
trying to fix them and getting totally
frustrated because they're not changing
that's going to burn you out on top of
that you're trying to then be X tox
person and you're trying to but you're
taking all that energy from trying to
fix that person it's not going away it's
hovering all the time like a hovering
anxiety and you're taking that into the
workplace and it's that constant on that
is draining you and you're going to
sleep at night still worrying about that
so that's a big thing so you need to
work on that and so taking thinker
moments helps to replenish and make us
aware of those and then you then
actively and deliberately put those into
your neuros cycle times you've got a
plan that prevents burnout so there are
days like I had we had team meetings all
week this week one of the days there was
15 hours I was so stimulated creativity
that I went to sleep at 8:30 woke up at
1:30 did 6 hours of creative work then
went into an 8- hour meeting the next
day I only did three hours of work and I
made sure that I did a lot of reading
and a lot of you know walks and relaxing
and just putting stuff back not
generating out and um resting and but I
know how to do that and that's how
prevented burnout but if I did another
15-hour day which I could easily have
done because I was so stimulated and
also if I wasn't working on something
that was worrying me which I am working
on something that's worry me I would
have put those two together would have
burnt out so that's my advice to people
find out through the Thinker moments
what is the draining stuff and make a
plan to do neuros Cycles to then get an
action to deal with that and then at the
same time learn to um to in the think of
moments you re replenishing if if you're
having 15 hour days or long days or
whatever you need to make sure that you
then counterbalance that with less hours
if possible the next day and if you do
that you'll find that actually you'll
achieve in those four hours what you
would have done in 15 anyway um because
you know you you just speed up your work
because you've given yourself time to
rest does that make sense it does and if
I was to take a thinker
moment um for three minutes every hour
you're suggesting well anything from 30
seconds to three minutes every hour
and probably not a thicker moment is not
scrolling on Instagram no it's closing
your eyes and it's just looking at your
keyboard if you're at a computer it's
literally closing your eyes and looking
at your keyboard or it's just looking
out the window and staring BL but
closing your eyes yeah you can close
your eyes if you want I would recommend
it but you don't have to because you
might be in an office with a bunch of
people and they might think you're nuts
so it's what you feel so sometimes I
close my eyes sometimes I just will
stare off into the distance with a
vacant look in my eyes and that's when I
do it and I've trained myself at first
you're going to forget to do them and I
make sure that I do at least a 10-minute
one somewhere during the middle of the
day and it's it's just something you got
to train in it they are absolute burnout
preventers and this is one of those
habits
that um also causes you to course
correct is that accurate maybe because
midday to your point wow I've been
burning so much energy up with this
whole other part of my mind of my brain
of my emotions worrying about a
situation I can't fix wow I've really
got into this social media Loop but
that's not my most high value task right
now but I find myself sometimes getting
into a loop checking the Doom scroll or
rather it's like or I just or The Loop
loop from I wonder if anybody replied on
Twitter let me check out the YouTube
comments has anybody replied over on
Facebook yet what are the YouTube is
anyone engaging on Instagram stories I
finish I check my email and I do it
again kind of just for the dopamine Loop
and sometimes it's hard for me to break
out of that like to kind of reset and I
just keep going back for it and I even
kind of know I'm doing it but I sort of
stay in it and it's partly related to
procrastination you're saying a thinker
moment is are non-conscious is able to
communicate with us and say hey get back
on track you're wasting your energy is
that accurate absolutely so your
nonconscious think of your nonconscious
like a giant infinite forest and every
tree is every experience you've ever had
built into a thought network with
memories from whatever age in the womb
we start building memories to the age
that you're at now and there's Bunches
of green ones and dark looking ones that
would be the toxic experiences and they
different sizes and the newer memories
memories in the in the trees are or the
small trees so the newer thoughts or the
so in other words just think of that and
then through the middle you've got this
Dark Forest that's beautiful beyond your
the most Exquisite thing that you've
ever seen think of that as your wise
mind and that's where you reside that's
the Unice and you your Unice your wisdom
resides there and it scans and it sees
okay that is lots of pulsing energy at
that particular cluster of trees and
it's creating a viral spread through a
bunch of other trees shs the
nonconscious finds that sends that
through the sub conscious which is a
portal into your conscious mind as
wondering thoughts as intrusive thoughts
they are your new best friend so in a
think in the neur cycle you're going to
find them when you've actively neuros
cycle daily and when to find them in
during the course of the course of a day
to help yourself and to activate the
default mode Network take those thinker
moments and then that helps to pick up
on those things and it'll help the
procrastination as well because
procrastination just basically is where
we feel so caught up and get burn very
often burned out in procrastination go
together um because you kind of you lose
a little bit of hope you don't some
things are blocking you and it's just I
don't know what to do so it's and then
you get scared to do it so
procrastination so you've got to tap
into unconscious wisdom that's going
where your answers for your for what you
want to do are there and we've got it
it's there we we are wise and you can
test your wiseness people come to you
all the time everyone comes to each
other you you for advice someone will
come to you and say hey Sean I've got
this and they tell you something and you
give them the most amazing advice you
think GE I wish I would reply that
myself I mean we really have got wisdom
in us kids are fantastic with wisdom
draw on your children's wisdom tell them
scenarios they will tell you the most
simple things that are the most
incredible wisdom you know that's also
wrote this book help how to help your
child clean up their mental mess which
is how to help parents help children
parents teachers Etc do the neuros cycle
from as young as two and three so they
can then develop these skills as early
as possible well I'm I'm excited to read
that one as well I have a three-year-old
now and a oneyear old so so that is the
season that we're in okay I want to
honor your time we even have a brainy
character just these cartoons throughout
this book teaching the neuros Cycles
I've created a brainy character and
brainy walks your mental health Journey
with you and brainy has a superpower
called the neuros cycle so the character
and we have a coloring book as well is
then um the character in and even the
adults love it inner child work whatever
but for kids this is an amazing tool
because brainy is throughout the book so
you always you know brain is helping you
live life oh man I love it so much and I
do want to honor your time but do you
have a few more minutes as we land the
plane I've got about two minutes and
I've got another interview in 10 in
about 5 minutes after that so I'll have
just need a couple of minutes to swap
over okay perfect so let's let's uh land
the plane I do want to mention
everything all the uh books and
resources will be in the show notes you
can also check out of course how to help
your child clean up their mental mess
and how to clean up your mental mess
that corebook to learn this newo cycle
check out the app and there is a 20% off
promo code that you can grab in the
description last question
what do you see how can businesses stay
ahead of the curve if a business owner
uh businesses stay ahead of the curve
leveraging upcoming insights uh for the
world of cognitive Neuroscience I'm a
Founder CEO I want to help my team
implement this any parting words so that
uh we could have a better next one five
and 10 years by tapping into cognitive
Neuroscience well cognitive Neuroscience
is based on the reductionistic principle
of the brain produces the mind and it
doesn't because the brain produces the
brain responds to the mind so first
thing that I would advise is to shift
your perspective and realize that the
future of your business as a business
leader and any business leader anyone in
business anyone is to tap into the
wisdom of your nonconscious so cognitive
Neuroscience is actually going to limit
you it's not going to grow you even
though that's the word that's used
because cognition brain doesn't produce
thoughts the brain responds to the mind
and mind builds the thoughts into the
brain so just it's a slight shift but
it's a paradigm shift that will shift
how you look at yourself so you're not
controlled by your brain and it's not
that your brain is producing patterns
that make you function in a certain way
we the Mind changes the brain and if we
change the brain in the wrong way then
we create driving patterns that will
influence us in the wrong way so our
power comes on in understanding that so
in terms of getting ahead of the game we
need to build our brain so we need to um
be with our mind with our wise mind
decide what areas related to our
business do we need to know more about
so what studying do you need to do it
doesn't mean to have to go back to
school you can if you want to but
there's knowledge out there there's
books out there there's entrepreneurs
out there there's courses out there what
is Rel is linked to your field that you
need to get new knowledge and that new
knowledge as you expand your knowledge
base and build your brain so your
intelligence and creativity will rise
and you may not directly use that input
but the process of looking in your field
and expanding in your field and tapping
into a bit of philosophy too
the philosophy which is science science
is knowledge it's all knowledge um helps
you think a bit more broadly and that
way you build a knowledge base that
increases your resilience and enables
you to then draw draw on you know you
may never know you may read 10 books and
then there's one phrase in one of those
books but the exercise of building your
brain has changed your networks and
increased your intelligence and
creativity and that's what you want to
grow your business in another Direction
Dr Caroline Leaf thank you so much for
coming on the think media podcast check
out her social medias and all of her
resources in the show notes and we will
see you in the next episode of the think
media podcast